Ahzubillahi mina shaytana rajeem, bismillaha rahmaana raheem.
Alhamdulillah iladilah yablughumidhatahul ka'iloon, wala yohsina'a ma'ahul aaddoon, wala yo addihaqkahul mujtahidoon.
Alladi yo drikhubu 'adhalhimam, wala yanaaluhu gausal fitan.
Alladila isalisi fatihi haddun mahdudun, wala naatun maawjudun, wala waktun maadudun, wala ajalun mamdudun.
Fatal Al Khala Iqabi Qudratihi Wa Nashar Al Riyaha Bi Rahmatihi Wa Wattadabis Sukhuri Madana Ardihi Wa Salatu Wassalamu Ala Said Nalim Ambia Iwal Mursaleen Khatiman Nabiyeen Sayyidin Al-Mumadjad Bashir Al-Musaddak Nadir Al-Muayyad Al-Mustaf Al-Amjad Mahmud Al-Ahmad Abul Qasim Muhammad Wa Salatu Wassalamu Alawasi Alib Nabi Talib Ashraf Al-Wasiyeen Wa Amir Al-Mumineen
Wassalatu wassalamu ala saydna limamit tayyib Sahibid dawatin nabawiyya Wa saulatul haydariyya Wa ismatul Fatimiyya Wa shujaatul Hussainiyya Wa ulumil baqariyya Wa maaqil Jaafariyya Wa hikmatul Isma'ailiyya Wa judeul Muhammadiyya Fa sallallahu alayhim Wa ala alayhim Wa salimuhum tasliman kasiran kasira Allahum mala 'ilmalana llama alamtana inna ka intal alimul Hakeem
Allahumma alim na bima yanfa ana wa yanfa ana bima alamtana Allahumma inna na'udhu bika min ail min la yanfa wa min qalbin la yaksha wa min aainin la tadma wa min nafsin la tashba Allahumma inna na'udhu bika min da'awatin la yusta jabulaha wa min mun karatil akhlaq wa la amal walahua Fa'amma ba'adiyakul subhana wa ta'ala fi kitabihil karim baadana kula a'udhubillahi mina shaytana rajim bismillah rahmanur rahim
Abi Sharahli Sadri Wa Yasir Li Amri Wahlul Ruqdatam Millisani Yathkahu Kawli Allahumma Inni Aozubika An Adalla Ao Udal, Ao Azila Ao Uzal, Ao Aslim, Ao Uzlama Alayya Ao Ajhal Ao Yojhal Alayya Allahumma Sabbitna Indal Mawtibila ilaha illa Allahu Allahumma Jaal Namin Alladina Aamanu Amila Salihat Watawa Saubil Haq, Watawa Sabr Amin Ya Rabbil Alameen Once again Assalam Alaikum wa Rahmatullahi wa Barakatu.
So, in the previous session, we looked at the.
Term Aalim which is basically anything and everything that can be known by the Aalim in order to enable him to recognize the Aalim right because you need the presence of an object before you can gain knowledge about it you know like for example in order to learn about human physiology we need a human body.
Right for mathematics we need numbers so we need physicality like we need physicality to exist before we can study physics so as human beings we cannot gain knowledge about a subject without the object for that study so the Alam is the object that gives us knowledge about the Alim right which is the subject so
We then looked at the statement Rabbul Alameen to understand that Allah is not just the master of this universe, but of everything that can be known by the human intellect.
Therefore, everything that exists in creation is a reflection of the Alien.
Whether it is physical, whether it's metaphysical, conceptual, spiritual, imaginable, right?
No matter what it is, it all reflects the Alien in some
way shape or form.
So the fact that he created this infinite universe just for us, I mean that reflects not just on his glory and his magnificence but also on his generosity and the vastness of his Rahma.
So everything is basically a reflection of the divine.
Now we'll continue this conversation forward and just to further elaborate on
on this concept and put it into perspective, there are two fundamental questions that surround the understanding of God.
The first is who is God?
And the second is what does He want from us?
What is our purpose?
These are the two essential questions that mankind has grappled with from the beginning of time.
Who is God and what does He want from us?
You know, all religions have come to basically answer these questions.
The first question of who is God?
It includes other, you know, smaller questions like, you know, what are his capabilities?
What are his attributes?
What is the personality of God?
Right?
What are his traits and so on.
And the second question of what does he want from us?
It includes these smaller questions like, you know, why did he create this universe?
What is the purpose of our existence on this earth?
What is the purpose of the earth itself?
You know, what are his expectations from us?
Things like that.
Now to answer both of these questions, Allah gives us a very simple and straightforward formula through a verse in the Quran.
Okay.
He says,
He mentions two broad categories in this universe.
Oh, sorry, in this verse.
Right?
The horizons and the soul.
Now, what is the horizon?
Simply stated, it is everything that exists outside of us.
This physical universe, that's what exists outside of us.
And then what is Anfus?
It is the soul.
It is the spirit.
It is everything that exists inside of us.
In other words, the spiritual universe, right?
Because we are souls.
We are spirits, essentially.
So what lies outside of us is the horizons in the form of the physical universe.
What lies inside of us is the Nafs, which is our spiritual universe.
So how does Allah answer the question, who am I?
He answers it through the horizons.
He answers that question through this physical universe and everything that exists within it.
And how does he answer the question, what is it that I want from you?
He answers it through the nuts, through our own creation and our own existence, by the creation of our spirit and soul.
And this is what I constantly keep referring to as the genius of Allah's design.
I mean I for one find it incredibly amazing how he answers these complex and impossible questions with such a simple formula.
And I hope by the end of this session you will appreciate that as well.
So just keep this formula in mind as I explain the details and you'll see how amazing the solution is.
I mean at least it is for me.
I mean in my personal opinion this is my absolute proof of the existence of God and Quran being the message of Allah because you know this kind of perfection in design it simply cannot exist at human level because you know human beings have a tendency to complicate things right so such a simple design just amazes me constantly and everybody has their own perspective by which they consider you know they find the proof of
the validity of God and religion and things that for me this is it.
And this is also Allah's solution to the problem that you know that theology faces today in modern day about the existence of God.
And the problem today is that we try to invent and apply our own formulas to prove Allah's existence.
And that is where humanity goes wrong.
Because
the fact of the matter is that he has already given us the formula in the Quran which is a very simple solution to derive at that same conclusion and it is the only formula it is the only formula that will actually work we can see this right today the world is like so confused about it because they're just not looking at the right formula and when you try to apply your own formulas to something it never works because this universe is Allah's Kingdom it is his design
So we have to follow his rule, his formula.
And this is something we can find plenty of example of in this world.
I mean, if you have an iPhone, you have to use it according to Apple's specification, not your own.
And if you try to use it in any other way than it is designed for or it's supposed to work, it's just not going to work.
So Allah's formula for His recognition and His intention is the Aafaq and the Anfus.
It's as simple as that.
Now, let's break that down and we'll look at each component in more detail so that we can appreciate what He means by that.
And I'm going to get a bit technical here, so please bear with me.
But I think it's really important to understand these technicalities to get to the final image or that concept.
So let's start with the first part of the formula which is the Afaq, the horizons.
And what did I say?
What questions does the Afaq answer?
It answers questions of who is Allah?
What is he capable of?
Why is he even worthy of my worship?
You know, my willing slavery and servitude to him?
What makes him so glorious or magnificent or so incredible in my eyes?
that I should actually consider him my master.
We've looked at some of these, you know, we've answered some of these questions in the past, right, with the session on the master and the slave and the relationship and all of that.
But today we're going to look at it from a different perspective.
So Allah says that He answers these questions using the signs in the Aafaq.
His signs in the horizon or in this physical universe.
And
I Covered this topic to some extent in one of the previous sessions on that conclusions of reflection That's why I asked everybody to revise that because a lot of that sort of it's more of a continuation of that concept and In that session we looked at the prerequisite for understanding this formula right so
That is again something we find evidence for in this world that if there is, you know, you need a child has to reach a certain level in order to be able to understand complex formulas.
So everything has a prerequisite, right?
If you're in the 10th grade, the prerequisite is that you have completed the prior education.
So the prerequisite for understanding this formula is a sound intellect and a pure heart, which the Quran refers to as lub, right, the core.
And the Quran calls these people Ulil Al Baab, people of pure hearts and sound intellects.
Because it is the combination of the two that allows us to perceive reality as it truly is.
And the second requirement of the Quran is, you know, to understand this formula is an uncontaminated or pure fitra.
the natural predisposition that we're all born with, which actually stems from, you know, a pure heart and a sound intellect.
If you have a pure heart and you have a sound intellect, your fitra will be pure.
That's how it basically they go hand in hand, right?
So those are the two prerequisites for understanding this formula.
The loop, the combination of pure heart sound intellect and an uncontaminated fitra.
Now the device that allows us to study the universe and learn about it we know is the intellect.
And the way it works is by defining and limiting things.
So you can think of intellect as the container and knowledge as the content that is placed within that container.
Now knowledge or ilm
Very simply defined, it is the understanding and the recognition of the true reality of things.
It is the understanding and the recognition of true reality of things.
And the foundation of that understanding, it first involves a concept, which is tasawwar in Arabic.
You have to create a mental image of something.
It is the conceptualization of that reality, which is then followed by a hukum or a ruling, which is a judgment about the authenticity of that reality.
You can't judge something until you've first created that concept.
So the Arabs say, Al hukmu ala shayin farkhanan tasaburihi that before you can judge a thing, you must first define it and understand it in all of its comprehensible dimensions.
And then once you conceptualize that reality, you can pass a judgment on whether it is true or false, whether it is good or bad.
You understand?
So that is why I want to get a bit more technical so that we can create a proper image and then we can pass a ruling on it rather than just saying, okay, this is how it is and this is the way it is and this is right.
So it makes it more just for us to be able to appreciate and get convinced about this reality.
So now this is an image that is quite busy.
It has a lot going on, but I'll break it down to just follow along with me.
So I'm going to begin at the bottom left corner, which is the empirical section.
Now, this diagram has to do with propositions.
So how do we human beings, how do we learn something or understand a reality?
How do we conceptualize things?
Scholars say that there are three types of propositions that human beings follow.
First of all, what is a proposition?
Let's just start there.
A proposition is a statement or it is an assertion that expresses a judgment or an opinion.
So if I propose to you that fire burns or fire is bright,
Now you take, that's a proposition, right?
Now you take that proposition and based on your observations, you conclude whether that statement is true or false.
That's how propositions work.
There is a statement and then you use observations to sort of validate that proposition.
So scholars say that there are three types of propositions for human beings.
You have the empirical proposition, you have rational propositions and you have philosophical or revelatory propositions.
Now let's talk about these individually.
So I'll start at the bottom left of imamate which is the empirical proposition.
So this is where it starts.
The first is always empirical propositions which are based on our observation or experience.
And this utilizes the five senses that we all human beings have, right?
Sight, hearing, smell, taste, touch.
So this is why these empirical propositions are also called sensory propositions because it involves the five senses, right?
Now, all of these senses, these five senses, they deal with the realm that can be witnessed, which the Quran refers to as Ala mush Shahada, right?
The physical realm, the witness realm.
So when I propose to you that fire is hot, when I propose to you that the fire is bright, when it combines with oxygen, combustion takes place.
These are all empirical or sensory propositions.
Right?
Because you can observe the validity of these propositions using your five senses.
Okay?
Now moving to the bottom right of this diagram, the second are rational propositions.
which are logical propositions.
They're not sensory in nature, they are logical in nature.
Like for example, if 3 plus 2 equals 5, then 5 minus 3 must be equal to 2.
Right?
These are not, this is not a sensory proposition, it's a rational proposition.
These propositions or these types of propositions, they work through inference.
but they require empirical evidence.
So for instance, if I see smoke rising in the distance, I can infer that there is fire burning there.
Now, even though I'm unable to see the fire itself, you see, but based on my prior sensory knowledge that when something burns, I have seen it emit smoke.
So I can rationally deduce that there has to be a fire there.
But then if smoke is the only thing I'm factoring in,
My inference could be wrong, right?
That smoke could be coming from a large group of people having a cigar party.
So then what is needed to maintain that original rational proposition of fire is more empirical evidence.
I need more data to prove that rational proposition.
So if I start walking towards that smoke and I see things getting brighter and the air getting warmer,
which are attributes of fire, then the probability of my rational proposition of there being a fire in the distance, it increases, you see?
Because now I have more sensitive data, more empirical evidence in the form of light and heat to support my rational proposition.
So in other words, the more empirical evidence we have, the more sensitive evidence we have,
the stronger the rational proposition becomes.
Make sense?
This is how Sherlock Holmes works.
Those of you who have seen the movie or the show, Sherlock Holmes uses empirical data, sensory data, to deduce rational propositions.
Now, at the top of the triangle, we have philosophical or revelatory propositions.
right this is the third type of proposition these are the Quranic propositions that talk about Alem Al Ghaib the unseen realm okay these are Quranic all most of Quranic propositions they deal with the Alem Al Ghaib the unseen realm it talks about the existence of a creator it talks about the existence of angels a divine message messengers come sent by God day of judgment heaven hell
This is all pretty much what the Quran talks about.
It offers philosophical or what we call revelatory propositions.
Revelatory from reveal because it's revealing the unseen world.
That's why it's called revelatory.
It proposes the idea of an afterlife.
It proposes the idea of a day of judgment.
These are all the things that we put our faith in.
Iman, our faith is grounded in these revelatory propositions.
That's the ultimate goal.
But how do we get there?
How are we able to believe in these completely unseen metaphysical spiritual propositions?
How do we do that?
Now think about the best way possible to reveal a hidden realm
to intellectual human beings.
Put yourself in Allah's shoes.
The simplest way to model or fashion, you know, for us to, I guess the simplest way would be to model or fashion a physical universe on the exact same principles as the spiritual universe.
That would be the simplest way.
Let's just create a physical model of that spiritual model.
working on the exact same principles so that everything in the physical universe points back to the workings of the spiritual universe.
That would be the most simple and the most efficient solution.
Because it has to cater to an intellect and that's what the intellect works with.
It works by limiting or defining things.
And you cannot define things until they are physical in nature.
So that would be the most simple solution.
Now the object that points to a destination, that is not the destination itself, but points to the destination is called what?
It's called a sign.
What is the Arabic word for sign?
Ayah.
Right?
So Allah says, We will show them our signs, our evidence, where?
in the horizons.
What do we find in the horizons?
Empirical data, empirical evidence.
Everything we find outside of us in the physical universe is observable data, sensory data.
Right?
Everything we see around us that is physical in nature, these are things that we can see, hear, touch, taste, or smell.
So Allah says, Sanuri him ayatina fil aafaq wafi anfusihim and within their own selves, within their own souls.
Because as rational human beings, we can deduce and infer rational propositions through that empirical data.
Therefore, Sanuri him ayatina fil aafaqi wafi anfusihim We will show them the evidence of the unseen realm
in the form of empirical and rational data of this universe and in their souls.
So the soul, which is capable of understanding rational propositions, will use the empirical evidence found out in the horizons.
How simple is that?
And how much evidence are we going to provide?
Unlimited evidence.
so much evidence that it will become absolutely undeniably clear to them that these revelatory propositions are true.
So for example, Quran tells us that Allah is the creator of this universe.
The fact that this universe is a created entity
is supported by our rational and empirical observations.
Because we know that there was a time in the past when this universe did not exist.
We also know that there will come a time in the future when it will return back into non-existence, right?
So existence and non-existence are both attributes of creation.
Therefore, rationally speaking, we can deduce that this universe is a creation.
Now, empirical data confirms that every creation necessitates the existence of a creator.
So, if this universe is a creation, it must also have a creator.
Right?
That's what the Fitra, the Lub, that's what it concludes.
So, then when Quran says, Allah is the one who created the heavens and the earth.
That revelatory proposition from the Quran then gets backed up and supported by our empirical and rational evidence that is found in the horizons interpreted by the soul.
Now, if we can believe this particular proposition rationally, logically, it makes it easier to believe when Allah says that he also created a spiritual universe because logically
You know the one who has the power to create this physical universe must also have the power to create the spiritual universe because he created a soul.
The body is physical matter aligned with the physical universe but I also have a soul and a spirit which also means there has to be a spiritual universe.
So you see how these how the empirical and rational data come together to prove the revelatory data?
And if you can understand this phenomena, this concepts, you can truly appreciate the motive of the Quran.
This is why everywhere in the Quran, Allah asks us to reflect on the creations of the heavens and the earth.
He never asks us to reflect on the Creator or Allah Himself, never.
Because that would be impossible for us to do without empirical and rational data of this physical universe.
This is why he says, Inna fi khalqis samaavati wal earth.
Not inna fi samaavati wal earth.
Si khalqis samaavati wal earth, waahtila fil laini wal nahar la ayatin li uli lal baab.
No doubt about it, in the creation of the heavens and the earth and the conflict between night and day, there are signs for the people of intellect.
and the word lubb, ulil albab, right, the root word is lubb which is very interestingly used here because what does lubb mean?
It means a pit or a seed which is always hidden in the earth.
You see?
This is why the intellect is our vehicle of understanding because it can penetrate into the unseen through the seen.
via the scene.
It can deduce the existence of the hidden seed and the hidden roots simply by observing the existence of the plant.
We don't need to uproot and dig out the plant to conclude that rational proposition that it has roots, it had a seed, that's where it came from.
This is why Allah demands to reflect on His creations.
He asks us to take an outside-in approach.
Why?
To gather the empirical and rational evidence that He created for our intellects in order to make it easier to believe the revelatory propositions.
And this is why Maulana Ali said, La tafakkur fillaa, wala kin tafakkur fi khal filla.
Don't reflect upon Allah, instead reflect upon the creations of Allah.
Because in the witnessing of this universe lies the evidence for what exists beyond it.
You see?
In the witnessing of this universe, there is the evidence of what lies beyond it.
The more we reflect on this physical creation, the more it will answer questions about the spiritual creation and particularly its creator.
So, this is how revelatory propositions work, this is how Quran works.
Quran proposes an Allahu al-Aziz al-Hakeem, indeed I am Allah, the most powerful and full of wisdom.
And if you examine the universe, you will find the empirical and rational data to support that claim.
Your study will reveal
that this magnificent universe could only have been created by someone who is incredibly powerful and incredibly wise because there is a purpose behind everything that exists in this universe.
And if there is a purpose behind everything, everything in the Aafaq, if there is purpose behind its creation, how can the Nafs not have a purpose?
Therefore there has to be a purpose behind the creation of the soul as well.
So, the Quranic proposition of AnAllahul Azizul Hakeem is backed up by the empirical and rational evidence of this universe.
You see?
The Quran proposes Ar-Rahmanu Allamal Quran Khalaqal insan Allamahul Bayan The intensely merciful taught the Quran, created man, taught him speech.
A careful study of these
acts of teaching the Quran, creating mankind, granting him the ability to speak, they will just prove one thing, that this can only be the act of Ar-Rahman, someone who's intensely merciful.
Right?
So this is, you know, this is how the entire Quran works.
Allah is the one that there is no deity worthy of worship except him.
He's eternally living.
He is the ultimate maintainer of things.
Now empirical and rational data proves that you have to be alive in order to maintain.
Dead people cannot maintain things.
And we know that all life on this earth is temporary.
Every creation will inevitably die.
And if you're going to die, you're not going to be able to maintain.
You're not going to be able to sustain or provide those
Provide things for those who are dependent on you.
Therefore, only the ever-living, only the Al-Hayy can be the ultimate maintainer and the ultimate sustainer.
Only the Al-Hayy can be Al-Qayyum, which then supports the next revelatory proposition: La ta khuduhusinatun wala naum.
He never gets drowsy, he never sleeps.
Because we know from empirical data, rational data that drowsiness reduces mental capabilities.
It reduces focus.
Accidents happen when you lose focus.
Sleep completely eliminates it for a short period of time.
Therefore, the one who is in a drowsy state or an unconscious state, he could not be considered almighty or the ultimate maintainer or sustainer because focus and vigilance is required for constant maintenance.
So, that's how the entire thing works.
You know, if you just read the whole thing, all these other propositions, Lahu mafi samaawati wa mafil or Everything in the heavens and the earth belong to Him.
Mandaladi yashfar indahu illa bizni Who can intercede on anyone's behalf without His permission?
How did you do it?
Ya lamma bayna aidhihim wa ma khal fahum wala yuhaytuna bisha'i im min al mihi illa bimaasha wa si aakkur sa yissama waa'at wala yaudu hajzuma wa huwala ali alaazeem and He is the Mighty and the All Exalted.
If we carefully analyze and study these revelatory propositions in the light of the empirical and rational data that this universe provides, it becomes easy for the human intellect to believe in the original proposition which was Allahu la ilaha illahu
Allah is the one and the only deity worthy of my worship because no other creation in this universe whether it's animate or inanimate can fit that lofty description.
Therefore if I do choose an entity of worship it only makes sense that I choose Allah because it has given me all the rational and empirical data that I need to believe in that.
So that's the first part of the formula, right?
The design of the horizons, the Afaq, which provides the empirical and rational evidence to support the revelatory propositions offered by the Quran.
It gives us, the Alem Shahada gives us, gives the human intellect a means, a vehicle to understand the Alem al-Ghaib.
They give us a pathway to understand who our Creator is.
and the kind of magnificent capabilities he possesses.
You want to know how powerful he is, how amazing he is, how incredible he is?
Just look at the universe.
Because of all his...
the effects of his divine attributes reflect in his creation in this universe, right?
So this is the story of the Martian and the iPad that I covered in conclusions of reflection that how by examining the outward we get to the inward.
Right, so that's the first part of the formula, the aafaq.
I hope through this empirical, rational and revelatory, it makes it very clear of how this whole thing is working, how the design of Allah is working, right?
So that's the first part.
The second part of the formula was what?
Anfus.
The soul or the spirit itself.
And what did I say?
What question does the soul or the spirit answer?
it answers the question of what Allah wants from us.
How is that?
To understand that, let's go back to the point in time when Allah he decided to create the very first soul, which was Adam .
How did he describe his intentions to the angels in that story?
He says
Wa izqala rabbu kalil mala ikati inni jaailun fil arbi khalifa He said to the angels, I am going to create my caliph, my khalifa on this earth.
Now let's understand the meaning of this word khalifa properly to appreciate this verse.
The word khalifa, it comes from the root word khalifa, which means back or behind.
Okay?
Salafa is the antonym which means what is a head.
Okay, so you have, so Khalafa means the one who is coming behind, the one who follows.
In other words, the one who succeeds, the one who represents.
So Khalifa means a representative.
Wa is qala rabbu kalil malaikati inni ja'ilun fil ardi khalifa, the master said to the angels,
I am planning to create my representative on earth.
Now think about this term representative for a second.
A representative is a person that is chosen or appointed to act or speak on behalf of another person.
You choose a representative when you don't want to go somewhere, but you want to deliver your thoughts
your example, your actions to somebody else.
But you don't want to go there, so you need to choose a representative to do that.
Now the question you have to ask yourself is, if you had to choose someone to accurately represent you, what kind of traits would you want in that person?
Someone who has the same or similar traits, if not the exact traits, right?
same or similar traits.
Otherwise, how else would that person be able to represent you or your thoughts?
This is why, as we continue learning the story of Adam , we see that not only did Allah create Adam, He also taught him all of his traits.
He taught Adam all his names.
He taught Adam all his divine traits.
In other words, he trained Adam in all the divine attributes that he himself possessed.
And after that training, he presented Adam to the angels, and he challenged them with those traits.
And what did the angels respond?
Alu subhana ka la ilmalana illama alamtana inna ka antal ali mulhakeem
They said, May you be glorified.
We do not know anything other than what you have taught us.
We have not received the training that Adam has received.
Therefore, we admit that we cannot be your true representatives on earth.
That was the original argument.
Right?
Because initially they had a problem with that.
The angels had a problem when Allah said that I'm going to create my representative on earth.
What did they say?
They said, Do you really want to create a representative who will spill blood and wreak havoc on this earth?
we are the ones who are constantly praising and glorifying you we are the ones who can represent you on earth you know we are the ones who have the ability to be your true Khalifa why do you need Adam for that but then when Allah created Adam trained him in his attributes right built up his character and presented Adam before him they all accepted and in a sense validated and confirmed
And it's interesting how that process worked as well, because it's again the same thing.
They got the empirical and rational evidence for a revelatory proposition.
Now that Adam was manifesting those attributes, they saw those and they realized that they do not possess the same attributes.
And so what Allah said originally, his revelatory proposition was true, that , Adam is the one that is going to be my representative.
Now, by Adam, he just doesn't mean Adam , he means Adami, all of mankind, human being.
So, the angels finally accepted and validated that indeed it is only Adam or mankind that possesses the true capabilities to represent Allah on this earth.
This is the concept of Allah creating man in His own image.
because we possess all the attributes that our creator, our master possesses.
We share Allah's attributes.
We know Allah can see because He says in the Quran, the revelatory proposition says that He sees our actions and our deeds.
We know Allah can hear.
This is why He gave us the ability to hear so that we could accurately represent His qualities on this earth.
But not just that, also be able to understand what He means when He says that He watches our actions and hears our cries and supplications.
You understand?
Because if we couldn't see and we couldn't hear, we wouldn't understand what it means when Allah says that He can see and hear.
We know Allah can act.
because we have the ability to act and Allah says the Quran proposes every single day He is busy in work.
We know what it means to be busy because He created us with the ability to be busy.
We know Allah has the ability to love because the Quran says that He loves everything that is good, that is clean and that is pure.
This is why He gave us the ability to love and this is why it is in our Fitra, our natural disposition to love clean and pure things because it is a reflection of our Creator because that is what our Creator loves.
You see that?
We also know that Allah has the ability to hate and dislike.
Allah hates or dislikes corruption.
We know that because we hate and we dislike corruption.
He put it in our innate nature to dislike and be repelled and be disgusted with filth and foulness, which is what corruption creates.
Filth is corrupted material.
This is all because we have been created in God's image.
We have been created with the same divine attributes that Allah possesses.
so that we could be His true representatives, His true Khalifa on this earth.
So that we could truly come to know and understand our Creator.
You want to know what Allah wants from you?
It's very simple.
Just look at your own self and you'll have the answer to that question.
Why do you not reflect on your own self?
Just see what you want for your own self.
That is exactly what I want from you.
Subhanallah.
How simple is that?
I'm having goosebumps.
This is incredible, right?
Do you want justice?
Well, I want justice.
Do you want to be loved?
I want you to love me.
Do you like to be praised?
Does it make you happy when you're praised?
I like to be praised.
Do you like it when people are grateful to you?
Do you appreciate that?
I appreciate when my creation is grateful to me.
Do you feel angry when people mess with your possessions and your rules?
I get angry when you mess with my possessions and my rules.
You want others to make you a priority in your life, in their lives?
Well, I want you to make me a priority in your life.
You see?
It's amazing.
You read the Quran cover to cover.
There is not one thing that Allah demands from us in the Quran that you and I would not demand from someone else.
So if you want to know what Allah wants from you, all you have to do is reflect on your own self.
In that, in the Anfus are the signs for understanding that.
What is it that you would want for your own self from somebody else?
That is exactly what Allah wants from you.
You want to be treated kindly?
I want to be treated kindly.
You want to be treated like you matter?
I want to be treated like I matter to you.
You want credit for the things that you made?
I would like to be credited for the things I made for you.
And in fact for making you itself and making this universe for you.
This is why Shirk is the most hated thing that Allah hates the most.
Because you would hate it if you made an invention and somebody else took credit for it.
And so Allah hates Shirk.
Right?
It makes perfect sense.
And in that creation it answers all these complicated questions.
If you understand this concept of being created in Allah's image, it answers so many questions.
You have questions about the creation of this universe?
Ask yourself this.
Because you know you are created in God's image.
So Allah said I created you with the same abilities that I possess, right?
Because you're in my image.
I am Khaliq.
I am the creator.
I gave you the ability to create and construct.
I created you as Khalaq.
Can even a needle exist in your world unless you create it?
Then how can you even imagine being...
you know, being created in my imagine, how can you even think that this universe came into existence without a creator?
You complain to me about the state of this world?
You say, why don't I do something about it?
I did.
I created you.
I created you in my very own image.
I gave you all my powers.
Why aren't you doing something about it instead of complaining to me about it?
You complain about poverty, misery, why don't you spend out of your wealth that I gave you to make it better and easier for others?
You talk about injustice, why don't you spend out of your courage that I gave you and fix those injustices?
You see blind people, why don't you become their strength?
You see weak people, why don't you become their strength?
I gave you everything you need to fix the conditions of this world.
But you do not want to step outside your comfort zones.
All you want to do is complain and have other people solve your problems for you.
You would not like it if I depended on you all the time to solve my problems.
Right?
If I have the money
to live a good life and I come to you and keep borrowing money from you, you're not gonna like it.
You'll be like, use your own money, you have plenty of it.
Why are you coming to Me?
So if Allah says the same thing, what's wrong with that?
You are created in His image.
He created us as gods.
He said, you know, He created us as ilah.
Think about that.
Each and every one of us has been created with the capabilities of an ilah.
so that we can recognize and understand the Al-ilah.
So that we can understand who Allah is and what He wants from us.
Subhanallah.
This is incredible design.
If you want to answer questions about what I want from you, all you have to do is look within your own self and study your own capabilities and desires.
And you'll come to know what I want from you.
The one who comes to know of his own self comes to know of his master.
Because the slave has been created in imamate of his master.
This opens up a whole world of reflection for all of us.
There is so much to say on this subject that it's simply not possible for me to cover that in these sessions.
I mean, I've given you the keys to the kingdom.
I mean, you reflect and figure it out for yourself.
The more you reflect, the more you'll see.
And this is a journey each one of us will have to take independently.
You're going to have to reflect on this and find answers for your own individual questions.
But there is one thing that I will talk about today in this context.
I'll put, you know, one example in perspective for you.
And just so that we can appreciate this whole, you know, with Allah's demand being completely just, and that is the topic of rights.
As human beings, we have certain rights.
We are entitled to certain fundamental rights.
So based on what we've learned today, based on this formula, we have to also understand that Allah has rights.
Right?
Just as we have certain human rights, Allah has certain divine rights.
And human rights are based on divine rights.
Divine rights are not based on human rights.
Which means that if
For us human rights are important, then divine rights must be a lot more important.
And one of the rights that we all possess as human beings is to be treated with honor.
That is the most basic human right.
After what a person does, you know, after what a parent does for a child, after what a mother goes through to bring her child in this world, she gains a right of gratitude over that child.
After the hard work a sincere teacher or a dedicated teacher puts in for her students, she gains a right of gratitude from her students, a right to be respected, a right to be treated with dignity and honor.
Now, if we as created human beings, as created entities, if we understand and appreciate the rights of another human being over us,
then what we need to think of is the right of the one who created us all from nothing.
What is the right of the creator?
If these are the rights of a created entity for another created entity, then what is the right of the Creator over His created entity?
Who created us from nothing?
What is the right of Allah who brought us out of the wounds of our mothers in a state where we knew nothing?
What is the right of Allah who gave us hearing, sight and a beating heart?
It is His right that we become grateful to Him.
As human beings, when we provide for someone,
The very least that we can expect back is their gratitude, yes?
It would be fair, a fair trade would be to expect the same or similar act of generosity back from them.
That would be fair.
But if they are not able to do that, then the very least we can expect from them is their gratitude, because we've done something for them.
So then what about ?
We do not ask you for your provisions.
Indeed, it is We that provide you with your possessions.
So then what about that right of gratitude towards the One who takes nothing from us and gives us everything?
And any and every good thing that you have in your possession has been given to you by Allah.
If we create something for a purpose, right?
If we invent something for a purpose, as human beings we have the right to demand that it is used for the right purpose.
We know that.
We can demand that it be used to serve the purpose it was created for.
If not, we have the right to be upset.
If I give you a phone as a gift,
and you use it as a door stopper, I have the right to be upset.
So as human beings, we have the right to demand the proper use of things.
And we have the right to demand justice if that's not being done.
We have the right to sue the offender.
Then what about the purpose of Allah's creation?
And indeed I have not created jinn and mankind except to worship Me.
How are we fulfilling the rights of Allah?
Does he have the right to get upset and angry with us when we do not fulfill those rights?
So we all really have to think about this divine right, this divine formula that Allah has created for us
in this verse that He explains in this verse ...
We will show them our signs in the horizon and in their selves, in their own souls so that they can come to recognize who Allah is and what He wants from them.
May Allah bless us all with the wisdom to fulfill His rights and obligations and may He enable us to treat Him with the honor and the dignity that He deserves.
Because if any one of us in this world, any one of us was treated the way we treat Allah today, wallahi, I swear we would be extremely offended.
We would all pass judgment against ourselves if we were honest.
If we were treated by somebody else the way we treat Allah, we would all be offended.
And that gives us a window into understanding the mercy of Allah.
that He still loves us.
We would never love another person who did what we do to Allah.
And so this is the idea that because we have been created in imamate of the one who has ultimate rights.
And that is what we truly are.
I mean, think about that.
That's all we are, an image, a reflection.
Today we are a reflection of a distorted version of those divine attributes.
Because we are not real, right?
We are an illusion.
Human existence is an illusion.
It's just like a reflection in a mirror.
It's a temporary illusion.
We are here this moment.
We're gone tomorrow.
But Allah is real.
His rights are real.
His obligations are real.
So if we pay so much, we put in so much effort into the rights and the honor and dignity of a reflection,
What should be the rights and obligations of the real, of Al-Haqq?
until it becomes absolutely manifest to them that this horizon and the Anfus are all nothing but reflections.
I am Al-Haqq.
I am the real.
Everything else is just my reflection.
I'll end this session today with a beautiful story that I heard recently and you know I think it's quite appropriate with this topic.
Some of you might have already heard this story but you know there was this man who heard about this very learned saint, right?
So he decided to go pay him a visit and to ask him for advice.
So he travels a long distance and finally meets the saint.
So he greets him, he sits down next to him, shakes his hand and he says, you know, I've heard that you are a great scholar and a wali, a friend of Allah.
So please give me some advice so that I can benefit my life and my hereafter.
So the saint, he says to this man, he says, my only advice to you is this, if you do not consider Allah your superior, then at least consider him equal to you.
If you do not consider Allah your superior, if you do not consider Allah superior to yourself, then at least consider Him an equal to you.
You know, the man upon hearing this advice, he thinks to himself, what kind of a silly advice is this?
I mean, who would be so stupid to consider Allah his equal?
Of course Allah is superior.
Is this what I traveled all this way for?
I wasted my entire trip.
visiting the so-called saint.
Now he's thinking about all of this and the saint is reading his thoughts.
So the saint says to him, you must be tired from your long journey.
Why don't you spend the night in this inn today and then leave in the morning?
And since the man was tired, he agrees to that and he spends the night in the inn.
The next morning when he wakes up, he offers his morning prayers.
A servant comes to his door carrying a large tray.
On one side of this tray, there was fresh breakfast for this man.
It had four eggs, four butter toasts, warm butter toast, two pieces of chicken, two glasses of orange juice, like all this really great awesome breakfast.
On the other side of that same tray, there was yesterday's food.
Some stale bread, you know, some lentils, something like that.
So just as this man was about to sit and eat, a beggar comes to the door.
And he calls out to this man and he says, in the name of your creator, I ask you for help.
In the name of your creator, I ask you for help.
I haven't eaten for two days.
For the love of your master, please give me something to eat.
Please feed me.
So what does this man do?
He gives the stale bread and the lentils to the beggar and he eats the fresh fruit.
Once he's done with his breakfast, he gets ready to leave and he decides to visit the saint again, you know, to bid him farewell.
So he finds the saint and he says his goodbyes and then just as he's about to leave, the saint says to him, My son, remember my advice to you.
If you do not consider Allah a superior, then at least consider him equal to you.
Now the man just loses it and he yells at the saint.
He's like, What kind of a stupid advice is that?
Who in the world would be so stupid, so foolish to consider, to not consider Allah his superior?
Of course Allah is superior.
What kind of a childish advice is that?
Even a child knows such a simple thing.
I traveled all this distance to come and meet you because I heard you were such a great scholar and this is the stupid advice you've given me?
How ridiculous is this?
So the saint, he becomes furious at this man.
He says, listen.
This morning when you sat down for breakfast, there was fresh food on your tray and there was stale food on your tray.
A beggar came to you and asked you for food in Allah's name.
In the name of your creator, he asked you for food.
He asked you for food for the love of your master.
Had you considered Allah superior to yourself, you would have eaten the stale bread and the lentils and given that beggar who was hungry of two days the fresh food to eat.
Had you considered Allah superior to you, you would have done that.
You would have eaten the lentils and the stale bread and given that poor beggar the fresh food because he asked you in your Master's name.
Had you considered Allah equal to you, you would have shared your fresh food with that beggar.
You would have eaten two eggs, you would have given two eggs to him.
You would have eaten two toasts, you would have shared two toasts with him.
You would have enjoyed one glass of orange juice and given the other glass of orange juice to the beggar.
O wretched creation, forget superior, you did not even consider Allah equal to you.
Because if another person, another person that you love asked you for a favor out of respect and love for that person, you would oblige.
You did not even consider Allah equal to you, forget superior.
So I'll end today's session with the same advice first to myself and everybody else then, that if we do not consider Allah our superior,
then considering His rights upon us and remembering all His favors upon us, let us at least consider Him our equal.
Wa akhar dawaan alhamdulillahi rabbil alameen wassalatu wassalamu ala rasuli sayyidam al khatimin nabeen wassaid al-mursaleen walaqi wozi habibn bishrafil wassain wala aaymatimun zurayatim taibnatahim wassalayim al-fatih.